SILVANO LUCIANI: OK.
And we are on air from London
from our brand new studio in
Campus London.
And this is the first edition
of this EMEA version of
Google+ Platform office hours.
We will repeat, so stay tuned on
the Google+ Developers page
to see our upcoming events.
I have a public service
announcement.
Unfortunately, we had a
last-minute program, so we are
not able to have external
guests, because unfortunately,
we wouldn't be able to
add their audio in.
We will fix this.
And next time, we will have
a lot of external
guests for our session.
So let's start.
I will introduce the studio.
On my left, we have--
ADE OSHINEYE: Ade Oshineye.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And
on my right--
IAN BARBER: Ian Barber.
Hi.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And I'm
Silvano Luciani.
I'm a developer programs
engineer
on the Google+ platform.
Ade is a developer advocate,
and so is Ian.
The topic of our first EMEA
session is the history of API.
And we will see a very cool app
that Ian developed using
the history of API
in App Engine.
But first, an introduction to
the history of API, and who
better than Ade for this task?
ADE OSHINEYE: Thank you.
So I think you've all played a
little with history or taken a
look at it.
And it's trying to solve a
number of problems, but we're
trying to solve it in
a very Google-y way.
So the first thing
is, how does a
user sign in to Google+?
So we give you a sign
-in button.
You click on it.
It's sort of a standard OAuth
one, and the user signs in.
And then once this has happened,
you get an API that
lets you insert what we call
moments, which are activities,
into a private place
we call history.
The thing we're trying to do
here is, we're trying to
separate saving moments
from sharing moments.
If you think of it like it's
an upload, when you take a
photo, it gets instantly
uploaded to a private album.
And then you choose if
you want to share it.
And some of them you
may want to share.
Some of them you may
not want to share.
So if you're looking at my
stream, you'd have seen I just
shared a photo I've took of
my shoes and Ian's shoes.
It was pretty good,
so I shared it.
There were a couple of other
photos that weren't so good.
And I didn't share those.
So that's the insight behind
Instant Upload.
And we took the same insight,
and we took it to History.
We said, well, what if people
had a right to get a bus?
What would they do with it?
Well, they'd want to write
moments, which activities with
specific types.
And then the user would choose,
well, this thing
happened on this third-party
site that was interesting.
Do I actually want
to share this?
And if it's sufficiently
magical, then the user would
share that magical moment with
their friends, their circles.
And if it isn't,
they wouldn't.
But it would still be there for
the user to find later on.
So that's what we're trying
to do with History.
It's sign in, saving moments,
and then choosing to share if
a user feels it's valuable.
I think that's the heart of
the developer system.
Ian, do you want to--
IAN BARBER: Yeah.
So I think that's exactly it,
this ability to keep these
moments in this sort of private
place that you then
choose what to do with.
So in the same way as all of you
have looked at the moments
and looked at what's been
going on, we have to
understand how they can be used
and how you can build
things with them.
So to do that, I actually
decided to put together a
particular app look that's being
used to allow you to
have a to-do list
on [INAUDIBLE].
So what we have here is
something that's not even on
App Engine.
It just gives you a place
in which you can
make a to-do list.
And as you create items and
check them off, it pushes them
into History.
So we can go on here and
say, an important task
that I have to do.
Mark, will you just select
the main screen there.
Thank you.
So this is just the screen
that is just the
interface is there.
We can go in.
We can create items.
And they'll appear, and you can
check them off, of course,
when you're done.
So we can go here and close
off the Hello World.
Nothing particularly
special about that.
And we'll have a look at how
that's built in a second.
But the sort of interesting
thing is that this is then
going to push into your
Google+ history.
And then you can go back and
either share those moments out
if they were interesting for
you, or just kind of have that
archetype of things that
have been going on.
So if we bounce into my Google+
History, it takes
sometimes a little while, and
you'll notice this if you're
building something yourself.
It can take a minute, two
minutes sometimes, or an
actual moment to appear in the
History UI, the preview UI,
once you've written a moment
in there unless you have
something that comes up.
If not, we'll jump into
the code and get it--
ahh, there we are.
So we've just got some task
that's been added in here.
And if I share it out, it has
actually got the description
of the task.
So that's pretty
straightforward.
But how that's actually being
developed uses a few different
elements from History.
And these are the History
API itself.
It uses schema.org or uses the
kind of underlying code to the
[INAUDIBLE].
So we might be called to jump
in this at the moment.
It's just kind of an
introduction to multiple
different things.
Because this was built using
the History APIs.
This was built on Google
App Engine.
And then this was built using
Go, which I know are all three
kind of not necessarily things
you at home have used before.
So hopefully, I'll give you
an idea of how they work.
And particularly, we'll jump
through some of the functions
that those who have done some of
the more interesting stuff
will give you an idea.
Most of all of the code from
here will be-- all the code
from here--
will be posted up on to
code.google.com into the
repositories that all the other
office hours are into.
So before you go down looking
at the file, everything in
this case is included in just
one big Go file, one big Go
package to do that is doing
all of the work.
It just makes it easier
to look through.
And we need to declare just
three types up front-- one for
our to-do item, one for our
to-do list, which is a list of
items, and one for our
individual users.
And a good example of the real
work is being done in the Home
function here.
So in it, we set up a handler
for the different paths that
we're doing.
Much like with any other web
framework, we have to root a
certain path to a certain
bit of code.
So we're rooting the main group
of the main onto our
Home function.
In our Home function, we're
actually going to go through,
and we're going to offer the
OAuth URL to allow people to
authenticate themselves.
We're going to handle
a response for that.
And when we handle a response
from that, we're going to go
away, and we're going to pick
up the user's profile
information so that
we can display it.
So the first thing that we do
when we come in, you'll see we
create a new App Engine
context here.
Whenever you're dealing with
App Engine, the context is
kind of a central point that
gives you access to the
various APIs and functionality
that it gives you.
App Engine, because of the way
it scales and because of the
functionality it offers, isn't
quite like hosting something
just on a straightforward
web server.
You have to make sure that
you're using its functionality
in order to get the
best out of it.
So what we do when you first
appear is down here, we've got
no existing user.
So if there's no user ID, we
just extract the OAuth code
URL from the OAuth library.
So this is using the Go OAuth
2.0 library, which is
available for Go.
And that just generates based
on the config that comes out
of our developed console.
So once we've setup an OAuth
context with our client ID,
with our client's secret, and
with the various redirect
URLs, just as with any OAuth
situation, we will be able to
generate an OAuth code URL,
which we're going to use for
our sign-in link.
When we send the user after
that, they'll get prompted to
authenticate the application
if they haven't already.
And then they will be redirected
back to us here,
where we can actually take the
code and exchange it for a
user token.
Now, if you see where we have
the OAuth transport, we
actually have to set this up for
App Engine to use the URL
fetch mechanism.
Because once we're on production
App Engine, all URL
fetches actually go
through an API.
And go out to be rate controlled
and to be quote
controlled so that we don't have
rogue applications going
crazy and spamming a whole
bunch of stuff.
So we actually need to parse
in a new transport, and we
parse in our config , which
contains our client ID, our
client secret, and so on.
Then we exchange our code
for an OAuth token.
And that's the token we can
actually use to go away and
make calls to the Google+ API.
For the actual calls themselves,
we just extract
the client from the Go
OAuth 2.0 library.
That gives us back an
HTTP client we can
use to make the calls.
And we parse that into
our Google+ servers.
So right at the top here, we're
including two different
Google+ services out of the
Google+ client libraries--
sorry, the Google client
libraries.
We have the plus-v1 library,
and we have the plus-v1
moments library, which
I've just aliased to
Plus History here.
The reason we have two libraries
is that the v1
moments library, which is the
library with the history, is
actually still in developer
preview.
So that isn't going to work
for most of us on
a day-to-day access.
The regular APIs are in v1.
So we actually need both in this
case, because we're going
to be accessing some regular
profile information, and we're
going to be going away and
accessing History.
So once we have our new service,
we create a new-- a
new OAuth client, sorry--
we create a new Plus service
using the OAuth client.
And we use the People
Get method.
That's going to go away and do
a call to the RESTful APIs,
and just return the profile
information for the user
described as me.
Because we're wrapping that in
the OAuth context, that's
going to go away and get the
current logged in user their
information.
And what we're actually to do
with that is use that as both
the key for our cookie, and
we're going to store that
information in a memcache
instance so that we can
display the profile information
at the top here.
So as we say my to-do's, and
show my picture, that's going
to have been retrieved from that
profile and stored here.
We do that in very
straightforward way.
We just create a new user entry,
which we'll use through
the rest of the application.
And we're going to marshall
that into JSON.
So memcache stores
a byte array.
It doesn't store a kind of
arbitrarily structured document.
So to serialize it, we're just
going to stick it into JSON
and turn that into
a byte array.
We can pull out the structure
back into a user entry struct
just by using the Unmarshall
function, which you can
actually see in the Get User.
We'll hop into that
in a second.
Memcache itself, we just have
a struct called Item, which
has the key-in value.
And we set that into the
memcache library.
So that's going to go away.
It's going to store that value
against that key in memcache,
and allow us to retrieve
it later.
And we're going to use the key
as the value for our cookie.
So the key in this case is
actually just an MD5 over the
user's profile with a little
salting string, just to make
it slightly less guessable.
There's also a lot more you
could do here to get yourself
a secure ID, or just
generate a UUID.
There's no real need for this
to be linked to the rest of
the user's profile in any way.
It was just simpler for knocking
out some code to use
the profile there at
the user base.
So once we've done that, we
create a cookie struct, which
again, has just a value
and a name.
You could also set expiry
times in here.
And we use the HTTP library
to set them.
The situation we end up with is
that the OAuth token, the
user's name, the user's profile,
is all stored in
memcache for when we return.
And this means that we can send
that cookie back to the
user with the response.
And the response includes the
whole HTML of the page, which
is generated down here through
this Home Template Execute.
So Go comes with a built-in
templating language that is
pretty proficient.
It allows you to do most of
the normal tasks that you
would in a template.
This is the main HTML.
So you can see it's mostly
just regular HTML.
The template tags are
identified by the
double curly brace.
That is either going to output a
token, so in this case where
you see I'm doing double curly
brace user in the URL, that's
just going to output the value
of user in the URL.
Or there are certain keywords
you can use, like IF, which is
going to check for if
the value is empty.
If the value is not empty,
then it'll execute the
included condition And you
can do ELSE and so on.
Templates also allow you to
include other templates.
So you can structure your
document how you'd like to.
So down here where we have
the sign-in URL, which is
displayed when the user's not
logged in, when they are
logged in, we actually display
the list of items.
So that's this Work, Home, and
then any items that they have
entered into that.
And that's actually stored in
a list HTML file, which you
can bounce into here, that just
uses a loop over lists we
have given it.
So it's using the range function
twice, once for each
list, so Homework and so on.
And once for the items within
the list, which again includes
a subtemplate.
So it's very easy to nest
templates this way.
Once thing to notice if you want
to do that is that all of
them have to be within this
template that we're executing.
So if I just hop down to the
bottom here, when we actually
define those templates, we
need to make sure that we
include the others in them.
So we have here our
Home template.
So we're parsing in the
main HTML file.
And we're actually using Home
template again to parse in the
List and the Entry templates.
That means that they're all
available for that template to
be executed.
Otherwise, what will happen
is when it tries to go and
include the template
and execute it, it
will actually fail.
Because we haven't created
it in that.
So it's important to make sure
that any subtemplates you want
to use are available
for referencing
by that main template.
So if we just bounce up to the
main now, this gets us to a
situation where we
have the list of
items actually created.
And we can then see them,
and the user has the
ability to add more.
The main work of adding and
removing items is done in
JavaScript.
So when we load up our actual
page, we create some handlers
on the item boxes, in the item
entry boxes, and the little X
button allows you to delete.
So what we do is just associate
this function here
and to-do, which is going to
go away and just do an Ajax
post OAuth to our web service,
where it will create the item
or it'll do a post OAuth
to the item.
So the posts are very simple
just used in this case.
It's jQuery, just either adding
an LI to the screen
with the response from the app
post, or fading out and
removing the LI if we no longer
need it once we've
completed that.
So in Go, those again are
just extra handlers
that we define here.
So we've got two Manage
List and Manage Item.
And those functions are a little
bit simpler if we look
to Manage List to begin with.
Manage List, it looks for
posting a new item, pulls some
form values out.
So these are the
posted values.
And then at the end, it's going
to just redirect back to
the location of the item.
And so this is the first kind
of interesting bit where we
come to think about History.
Because here is the point at
which we want to actually push
a moment to History.
So if a user's created an item,
we'd like to actually
update the Google+ History
and tell it about it.
But we also would like to return
the item to the user.
So if the user--
when the user gets redirected,
they get sent to a URL which
is specific to an item.
And that URL, if we see it down
here, will render using
the item template.
And that is Entry here.
So we're going to return
an LI that just has a
description of the thing.
It has the Close button.
But it's a snippet.
It's not a fully formed
piece of HTML.
If we request without the XML
HTTP request header set, which
means if we're requesting like
say a normal web request,
we're actually going to use
a different template.
And we're going to render the
moment +, which is going to
render a full page.
And in that page, we're going to
include schema.org markup.
Any of you guys want to cover
what schema.org markup is?
ADE OSHINEYE: Sure.
If you went on the site
schema.org, you would have to
start by, first of all,
understanding what are
microformats.
So microformats started with
a very simple idea.
You have a well-written
HTML web page.
And it describes some product,
some entity, some person.
And then you realize that it's
really hard for tools to
automatically understand the
structure of that page.
But then you realize after a
while that you tend to use
certain, very common
tag names.
And so the microformat's
committee realized they could
embed these attributes in the
HTML, which didn't change the
appearance of the page but which
surfaced the fact that
this page actually contains a
local business, or contains, a
person or contains a place.
And schema.org came along as
an attempt to say, well,
instead of having lots and lots
of different kinds of
microformats, what if you had
one ontology, one set of
microformats, or microdata in
this case, which let you say
this is a person, this is a
place, and this is a special
kind of place.
This is a local business.
This is a school.
This is a high school.
And if you'd made this ontology
extensible, so if you
could start a mailing list and
say, I'd like to add this kind
of entity into this hierarchy,
you get a really nice thing.
The beauty of this is that at
the simplest, all you need to
do is to say this page describes
a thing which has a
name, a description, and an
image, and a URL, so we can
know what page it's on.
But that's the simplest way.
And the beauty of this is that
it gives you control over the
snippets you see in web search,
but it also gives you
control of the snippet
that is shown in
your screen in Google+.
And coincidentally, it also
gives you control of a snippet
that's shown in Google+
History.
IAN BARBER: Absolutely.
Cool.
So if we could just put
it back to the code.
So what you can sort of
see here [INAUDIBLE].
When we go and request the URL,
when we add a type, the
URL that we get back just
contains this LI because we
did it with the XML
HTTP request.
But when we do it just from a
browser, we get a screen like
this, which is a fully
rendered page.
And that is where we are using
the markup as Ade described to
indicate what this page is.
Now I'm doing a terrible thing
for people that do a lot of
schema.org and using
schema.org/thing.
Because I didn't know exactly
what a to-do list was in that.
But normally you would
want to do
something a lot more precise.
Also, if you'd do
a creative work.
You'd do a blog post, whatever
it is that you're actually
covering, this is the most
generic and worst possible
thing you can use
in schema.org.
But I am indicating that, OK,
the body of this document is
an item scope of this type.
And within it, there
are some certain
properties that I have.
So I have a name, itemprop,
which I'm using
as a Task To Do.
I have a description, which in
this case is the text of the
task I put as EMEA office hours,
and I have an image.
So again, itemprop image here
indicates that this image best
describes this thing.
And if it was a person, the
image would be of the person.
So that allows--
even though this markup doesn't
affect how the page is
rendered, it, as Ade says,
allows search.
It allows sharing to pick up
those characteristics from
this HTML page.
So if I push them into History,
this is what the
History will retrieve.
So if we take a little look at
that, where in the Create
function we have this push
moment, what we're sending
across is the user--
sorry, I said push.
It should be delete.
What we have, we send across as
the user, the URL, so that
will be the equivalent
of this, and
the type of the moment.
So when you are creating a
moment in Google+ History,
you're not just saying
this URL happened.
You're saying that the user
took some kind of action.
The user has done something.
And there's a list of--
eight or nine supported?
ADE OSHINEYE: We support
a small set of common
actions right now.
The important thing is that the
user performs some action
on the entity at this URL.
That's the important idea.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So all of them
are documented in the
guide documentation in here.
You can find out everything
you need to know.
IAN BARBER: So, in this case,
because you're creating a new
thing to do, I decided to mark
that as a Create activity.
So we'll just jump down to the
Push Moment code here.
What this is going to
do is again, it's
going to use OAuth.
So we need to set up another
transport, and we
need to get our token.
So we're putting the token
that we have in our user
entry, which will normally be
coming out of memcache, and
we're creating a OAuth
token there.
And we're using the client that
we've retrieved from the
OAuth library for our Plus
History service.
Then we need to actually create
what we're going to
send to the Plus History
service.
So that is a moment, which is
defined as a moment struct.
And at its most basic level, the
moment has a target, and
it has a type.
The type is the-- in this case,
the Create activity that
I decided upon earlier.
And the target is the URL that
we're going to reference.
It's the thing that the user
is doing something to.
In this case, the user
has created this URL.
So we're going to parse through
a itemscope, which is
the struct that is
used for that.
We're only going to set
the URL in there.
There's a lot of values in there
you can set, but the
only one you want to set at
this time is the URL.
That's the place you're
referring to.
And then we just use the Moments
Insert, where we're
just going to say for the user,
me, the currently logged
in OAuth user to the vault,
which is the only place you
can send them to--
that's the one valid field
for that correction--
we're going to send
this moment, and
we're going to do it.
And that is going to go away.
And it's going to push the
moment over to Google+
History, where it will appear
as we saw it earlier just in
here like this, and then
users can reshare it.
So it's picked up the image.
That's the image that
was marked on it.
It's picked up the text that was
described, and it's picked
up the title.
So that's the description that
I put in the image and then
pulled out by schema.org
from that.
Now if we go back to here, once
this has been done, we're
pretty much done with the OAuth
part of this situation.
This is all we're using it for
in this case, is to just
continually push
those moments.
But that would've happened
sometime after the
user has logged in.
So because we're storing this
stuff into memcache, we can
keep it, and then as the user
comes back and interacts with
the site, we create the moments
in the background.
We're not asking them for
authentication again.
We're not checking on them again
unless that token has
expired, unless we need extra
privileges from them.
So this is something that
works well for a kind of
application situation.
One thing that we did realize,
or I did realize while
building this application,
that there is a slight
fundamental mistake about how
we've actually structured the
idea of this app,
my to-do app.
And it's a point Ade made, which
was when you're using
History, the first possible use
is for private actions,
the user taking a private action
but on a public URL.
And in this case, the URL
is kind of semi-public.
We have to have this thing
as a public URL that
anyone can go to.
But it's not really public
information.
It's not really something
that the user would be
best suited to do.
ADE OSHINEYE: I think one
example of that would be if we
were to make a post where it
got written to History that
Ade has checked in to Google
Campus London.
Google Campus London
is a big building.
So it's pretty public.
It's seven stories in the
heart of East London.
The fact that I'm here is
private, except for the all of
you watching right now.
IAN BARBER: So absolutely.
I think Ade has a really
good point.
I think that when you're
designing your own
applications, that's something
to keep in mind.
What's the public thing that
is being interacted with
privately by the user?
Even if the user isn't
necessarily particularly
worried about a very
private life.
Ade checking in here while--
ADE OSHINEYE: No, I've chosen
to share that fact.
IAN BARBER: But he chooses
to share it, exactly.
So the information
starts private.
And the user then chooses
whether they want to share it.
But the thing that is actually
being interacted with, it's
best if that is public
and that has a URL.
And that benefits you
in a lot of ways.
Because if your URLs are public,
then when you brought
them onto schema.org, then
they're going to share well.
They're going to look good.
But they're also going to
appear in search world.
Because you've got that
extra markup on that.
So the other interesting thing
that sort of came out from the
applications is worth just a
very quick look is that when I
actually started on this, just
to get something working, I
actually started on this
in JavaScript.
So rather than using the service
side flow, I did it in
the client slide flow.
Still using Go in App Engine
to provide the sort of
back-end story along with
the URL moments work in
JavaScript.
So it's interesting to
compare the two.
It's very simple and very
consistent across the
different languages.
Let us check out
a master there.
Oh no, sorry about that.
[INAUDIBLE]
And then we can bounce
back in here.
And what we see is that rather
than pushing those moments in
the Go part of the service,
we're actually going to push
them in the JavaScript.
So here's where we store the
item, very, very similar.
We're going to pull out the URL
of the actual item, which
was being returned in our
special response header, and
we're going to create a moment
just using JSON.
So obviously that's pretty
easy to work with in
JavaScript.
We just create the type here.
We create Activity.
And we add the URL
in as the target.
And then down here in this
Push Moment function, all
we're going to do is do a call,
a very simple call,
using the GAPI library off to
the plus-v1 moment vault
posting the JSON representation
of the moment
that we've parsed in.
So this is very similar to how
we were doing it before.
All we're doing is taking the
JSON representation of the
moment and sending that
over to Google+
using the OAuth setup.
So there we have setting the
token into the OAuth on the
GAPI library.
And we just make a GAPI client
and push actually to our next
[INAUDIBLE].
So you'll find once you've
actually implemented the
History API or any of the API
in one language, it's really
easy to then go and turn that
into another language.
This was not that complicated
to go and look from the G+
client code and turn it
into the code for the
Go Google API client.
And it's the same look in our
clients in PHP, Ruby, Java,
and any of the other of
the other languages.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So given your
double experience with both
the server side flow and the
client side flow, first one
with Go, second one with
JavaScript, which would you
suggest to a user?
Which one do you think is
more appropriate for it?
IAN BARBER: It's a really
good question.
I think that the difference is,
again, it'll depend on the
different kind of application.
So if you are building something
that is more of a
web application where you are
having longer running
interaction happening in the
background, so it's storing
something for a user, and
they're coming back and
interacting with it
occasionally, doing the work
at the server side just gives
you a lot more flexibility.
The user doesn't have to be
using the app right then when
you write the moments.
If you know that they're going
to do something and they go
and do it, you get a signal from
somewhere else, you can
still trigger that moment even
if they're not there with you.
If you do it in the browser
and JavaScript, then they
pretty much have to be running
that application at the time
for you to go away and
push the moment.
So it depends on the kind
of service that you want
to offer the user.
But that's always the thing to
focus on, is what's the user
going to actually see?
And why would they want me to
be pushing this moment?
And then once you know that,
go back and work out which
technology would be the
best basis to use.
ADE OSHINEYE: You should also
think about what happens in a
mobile context, which I may sign
in to the web app, and
then I may be using your mobile
app, and then something
may happen.
And you can decide whether
your mobile is going to
actually write the scripted
history from my phone, or
whether it's just going
to tell your server.
And then your server's
going to write the
history on my behalf.
IAN BARBER: Yeah, that's
a great point.
And I think you've got
that option to do
it either way around.
You can post on the mobile
client libraries, or you can
take from the server side.
Definitely worth considering.
SILVANO LUCIANI: OK.
Cool.
ADE OSHINEYE: I do have
one question, Ian.
We've got a very big
team now in Europe.
There's four of us.
So it's starting to
get confusing.
So where did you get
those icons?
IAN BARBER: Ah.
The icons are--
that's a very good point.
I should have mentioned
that earlier.
So these icons are actually
from a brilliant project
called the Noun Project This is
a collection of a variety
of useful and interesting icons
that have been released
as Creative Commons.
So you can go on there, and
as long as you give proper
attribution to the creators,
you can use
any of these icons.
They've got a great search.
And you'll find, in a lot of
cases, there's multiple
variance for any given icon.
So you can find one that really
sort of matches the
style of your product, a
really great source for
finding nice little icons
for scripting.
ADE OSHINEYE: I do love
the bicycle one.
I can see there's some really
interesting things you can do
around that.
IAN BARBER: It is fantastic.
And I've definitely enjoyed
having access to all of those,
including, of course, the
ever-important unicorn.
ADE OSHINEYE: Yeah, so why did
you choose unicorns for this?
IAN BARBER: He was the best icon
I could think of at the
time with limited searching.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So I have
another question actually,
about you have a lot
of experience
with different languages.
And I'd like to hear after this
what you think about Go?
What did you like about
writing in Go?
If there's something
that was--
IAN BARBER: I think Go
is-- it's strange.
It's kind of different from
other languages that I've
worked with more recently, where
a lot of the languages
that I've tried more recently
have been pushing down certain
paradigms around, say,
functional programming or
extremely object-oriented
programming, and
that kind of thing.
I think Go is in many
ways is very simple.
Its background as a systems
language has made it just
incredibly easy to just
kind of write code and
have it work well.
In this case, I didn't need to
use any of the concurrency
primitives and some
of the stuff that
really makes Go different.
But I found just as a language
that gives you that kind of C
feel, but with pretty much none
of the pain that comes
with C. I found it very
pleasant to work with.
And the documentation
online is excellent.
It is quite tricky to search
for it because the
language is called Go.
So if you search for Go and
almost anything, it's going to
be difficult to find
a result there.
But if you can get into the
documentation, which is just
on Go line, it's really,
really good.
And there's a great community
out there that have been very
helpful when I've
had problems.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Did
you have any other
questions, Ade, for Ian?
ADE OSHINEYE: No, I think this
pretty much covers it all.
SILVANO LUCIANI: I am watching
our event, and I can't see any
questions from external users.
So I would like, Ian, would
you remind that we will
publish this code?
IAN BARBER: Yes.
Yep, we'll put this up.
We'll put the links up on
the page afterwards.
But it'll be in the same
repository as all the other
office hour samples
from previous
weeks from the US variant.
SILVANO LUCIANI: OK.
And just another reminder is
that, as Ian mentioned and Ade
as well, the Google+ History API
is in developer preview.
So if you want to use the API
and see the user interface for
the moments that Ian has shown
us, you need to sign up for
the preview.
And you can do it at
developers.googl
e.com/plus/history/preview.
Any--
ADE OSHINEYE: I think that
pretty much covers it,
although I would say, if you try
History, you should really
play around with some
of the search stuff
we've done with that.
It's really quite clever.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And
give us feedback.
IAN BARBER: Absolutely.
ADE OSHINEYE: And if you have
any questions, we have a
mailing list.
IAN BARBER: Yep, and Forums, and
Stack Overflow, and we're
all over the place.
ADE OSHINEYE: You can always
talk to us on Google+.
IAN BARBER: And Google+.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And
Office Hours.
IAN BARBER: And Office Hours.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So to
close, I'd like to
say thanks for coming.
Thanks for watching us.
And thanks if you're watching
this recorded on YouTube.
Next time, we will have
interacting guests.
And next time it will be
probably two weeks from now.
We are still trying
to determine
which is the best schedule.
So if you have any feedback
about airing time, the day,
please let us know because
we will take it into
consideration, because we are
trying, as I said, to see
which is the best time
to premiere.
And thanks, Ade.
Thanks, Ian, for showing
your app.
And see you in two weeks.
IAN BARBER: Bye.
ADE OSHINEYE: Bye.